okay everybody this is it we finally
have official confirmation from Marvel
Studios about trailers so as you know if
you watched my last video Marvel has two
trailers releasing this week
Avengers four and Captain Marvel well as
I said in my last video it was leaked
that Avengers 4 it was going to be
airing on Monday during the football
game and that Captain Marvel would be
aired on Wednesday during Good Morning
America well like I said it was subject
to change because Disney didn't want
anybody knowing about the trailer
release schedule well it turns out they
did change it we're now getting Captain
Marvel Monday night during the football
game and Avengers 4 during Good Morning
America on Wednesday morning the good
news is that this is official this is
the first official news that we've
gotten concerning these trailers Marvel
Studios posted a brand new poster for
Captain Marvel and also said to tune
into ESPN's Monday Night Football to see
the brand-new trailer and they also had
an ad for it in tonight's game
so as you can see here the NFL did a
promo announcing that the Captain Marvel
trailer will be tomorrow so that's
official which means the Avengers four
trailer will be Wednesday morning during
Good Morning America that's December 5th
Wednesday morning Good Morning America
at 7:00 a.m. what's interesting is that
this is also when the Avengers for
prelude comes out so it looks like
they'll be releasing them at the same
time not sure why Disney and Marvel
decided to switch them it could have
been because of the leak but as of right
now this is how it currently stands if
they change anything again or they
switch them back again for whatever
reason I'll let you all know Disney and
Marvel can obviously do whatever they
want
obviously they just did with this switch
and like they did with the infinity war
release date they pushed it back they
may have decided to do Captain Marvel
first because she may be in the Avengers
4 trailer but that is just speculation
and is in no way confirmed but like you
all saw officially the NFL has announced
that there will be a new Captain Marvel
trailer premiering tomorrow night during
the football game that starts at 8:15
which puts the Avengers 4 trailer coming
out Wednesday on Good Morning America at
7 a.m. this is the week everyone the
Avengers 4 trailer so be sure to
subscribe to my channel but the
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything related to the
Avengers 4 trailer and Captain Marvel
trailer thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]